in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Julianne dropped by hi Julianne how are
you good are you better than I deserve
where you from Amarillo Texas who or
brings to Nashville I had a buddy
graduate from a fellowship up here
oh very cool how can I help today I am
25 I'm debt free
I make 70 thousand a year and I have a
fully funded emergency found a 10 grand
good for another five thousand safe for
a house way to go thank you
I was just curious do I need to wait
till I have 20% to buy a house or should
I just go ahead and buy one as soon as I
find one it's whatever you want to do
the advantage of waiting to 20% down is
and obviously you've done a great job
with your money for 25 years old man
you're way ahead of the curve doing your
rock star your ear oh but the advantage
of waiting is you if you do not put 20%
down you will get what's called PMI
which is called private mortgage
insurance is what that stands for and
what that is is foreclosure insurance
that the mortgage company requires you
to buy that protects them in the event
they have to foreclose on you it writes
them a check and because you didn't put
down a big down payment they're more
worried about that is where that comes
from the simply put that will cost you
about $75 a month per $100,000 borrowed
so it's 150 bucks a month $1,800 a year
for this insurance that's just stupid if
you know if you buy $200,000 house that
kind of a thing so that that's the
advantage of putting 20% down is you
avoid that obviously the disadvantage is
you're going to be renting for a year or
two more till you save up that 20%
however long that takes you in whatever
the situation that is so that's what
you're looking at on a first-time
homebuyer I don't yell at them about
that if you if you want to go ahead and
close on it you just know you got this
extra you know kick in the face expense
here that does go away one you can get
it dropped once you pay the house down
below 80% of the original amount
borrowed or 80% of value if you can
prove it to their satisfaction so on but
you got to
you know you're going to pay a premium
in the mean time and that's what it
comes down to but but I'm fine with you
doing it on a first-time now somebody
buying a second home and they've got
they got two hundred thousand dollars in
their pocket and they you know just
don't limit themselves and so forth then
no you need to your second purchase you
need to just put 20% down you need to be
smart and avoid that but in your case
you've done a really really good job
congratulations thank you good to talk
to you hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind